i'm vincent mooser i'm from
switzerland i'm presently the canada
excellence research chair in genomic
medicine at mcgill
and i'm very happy to have this
opportunity to present
a research program here the reason
i think i'm so happy to present this
research program is
because there is here an opportunity
to change the way medicines
are being discovered and developed and
there is a very
broad opportunity as well for
incorporating
ai as a way to explore the data
that are being generated and make sense
out of them
so what i will do here is first share my
screen
and my suggestion here
is that i will present these
program it will take me probably 15
minutes
and then i will stop and pause
and leave you the chance maybe to ask
questions by chat so i will not read the
chat
during my my presentation
my presentation is entitled large-scale
genomics
to support precision pharma rnd
this slide illustrates the various steps
which lead to a new drug if we're going
from left to right we're starting with a
disease say
coronary disease we need to identify
a target a molecule we want to modify
the functional activity or quantity
say hmg coe reductase then we need to
validate this target that means bring
data which will support prosecution of
this target
and tell us it's worth investing and
then
once target validation has been
sufficiently strong
then industry is starting the high
throughput screens
to identify what we would call hit which
gets refined
to candidates and candidates are then
tested first time into man
this is mostly to test the safety
and deliverability of new molecules
and one safety interoverability have
been demonstrated in healthy volunteers
phase one
then molecules are getting tested in
proof of concept
studies ie showing that the molecules is
doing what it's expected to do
if we're taking hmg reductase we're
talking about
lowering ldl cholesterol in
patients with high levels of ldl
cholesterol i'll get back to that
in one's proof of concept or park has
been achieved normally
drug discovery is finished and the
molecule are handled
into the hands of the drug developers
that means the guys while running big
phase 2b phase 3 trials until two
independent trials demonstrate efficacy
which normally
is needed for molecules to get approval
by regulatory agencies and go into the
market for phase four
or best marketing surveillance life
cycle management
we all know that it's very costly
it's very risky and it's very hard
to get new molecules takes 10 years or
more
usually more than billion dollars this
morning
joshua was telling about three billion
dollars
i think he's probably right and success
rate is extremely slow
small and so any piece of data
which would help peop people make
decisions
on whether or not they want to go from
one step to another
at each of these decision points any
piece of data
is appreciated to reduce
the risk or in other words increase the
probability of success
and also that's important as well
for attrition of poor molecules
genetics and genomics have been shown to
provide
valuable data for a few drugs
and i would like to illustrate this
point with
examples i will start with first
examples showing that genetics has been
really valuable
for this is understanding target
identification and target validation and
probably the best example that everybody
quotes
but i think is right is pcsk9 inhibitors
there is an interesting story behind
pcsk9
pcsk9 was discovered
and identified by naitsai at the
university of montreal
he demonstrated that gain of function of
pcsk9
was responsible for hyperlipidemia
in certain families but probably
most of the credits are going
whether it's right or not i don't know
to helen hops on this picture
i know helen hobbs well she was my
mentor i trained for three years in the
lab
and actually replaced jonathan cohen as
a postdoc
so what helen has done
is sequenced pcsk9 gene
in a number of people including people
with very low levels of ldl
and she found an individual n equal one
one one individual with
two separate mutations so two pcsk9
genes were
abolished she was complete knockout for
bcs canine
and she had zero level of ldl in
and that was important she had no
other conditions no heart
brain eye or no
liver condition and that was telling
industry
that if you were to have a molecule to
specifically lower ld
pcs k9 and inhibit this enzyme you have
little safety issues to anticipate
it will be safe and that's exactly what
did happen
an equal one
that's why based on these type of
studies
industry has decided to invest massively
in genetics and genomics
i've got here this quote saying that
glaxos was investing 300
million dollars to access the data from
bunny 3 and me
which as you know is a company
generating
genomic data for mostly
i would say recreational reasons but
they are also now moving into really
pharma
you can see gsk astra jnj
amgen investing 250 million dollars in
the uk biobank of sequencing this is
exactly for this type of purpose
another example whereby genetics has so
been so instrumental is proof of concept
study
and here i want to use this example
again of statins
the reason i'm saying statins is that
mike braun and joe goldstein
got their novel nobel prize for
identification of the ldl receptor
invitations responsible
for familial hypercrystallinia so that
really
validated stating this target
but an important paper was published
30 years ago 40 years ago now
that proof of concept that statins work
and this proof of concept
was demonstrated on seven individuals
seven patients were defective in the ldl
receptor
half of them it resided and the molecule
fixed the phenotype that shows the
power of human knockout
for proof of concept trials
a third example whereby genetics has
been instrumental in drug discovery and
development
is pharmacogenetics i'm taking here
probably the most emblematic example of
pharmacogenetics
this person here has developed a
hypersensitivity reaction to a
heavier an hiv drug and it is now well
known
that the there is a genetic
susceptibility to this reaction it's
called hlab5701
and now it's common practice to
one before prescribing about capital
because
now we know that these people have a
high risk
and drugs should not be given to these
individuals
and so i want to summarize here the
first part of my presentation
this is an overview of the examples
where biogenetics has been
really instrumental for black
discovering development and going from
left to right again
the statins brandon goldstein starry
pcskn hidden hubs nahib story
ccr5 inhibitors enzyme replacement
therapies
cftr modulators for ct fibrosis
and here a very well-known
story as well a plus c three and
descends a nuclear nucleotide for a rare
form of
familial hypertrophy statins cftr
modulators and enzyme replacement
therapies here
repurposing some examples rare and some
examples like a back idea
essentially what is striking and from
that was a lesson is that
is if not all most of the studies so far
are based on big
rare functional loss of function
mutations
we are going back into mendelian
genetics essentially
what we could call human
knockouts so human workouts are very
informative
this is an area which i have
i think pioneered when i was working for
industry
and actually i'm showing here a paper
that we published a few years ago now
whereby we systematically sequenced
200 genes of interest for pharma in 14
000 people
including six thousand people from the
cohort in lausanne switzerland which i
had co-created
called the colossal study and the
question we were asking is
other human knockouts in most genes and
the answer is yes
we can find human knockouts for
essentially energy provided
you sequence a sufficiently large number
of people
that was 2012 when we published that
stuff in science
four years later you could see here
geizinger's study fifty thousand exomes
the exome is the coding
portion of the genome it's not the
entire genome it's just three percent of
the genome it's the part of the genome
which
encodes protein and
at that time they had technology to do
50 000 and what you can see
here is if you sequence a sufficiently
large
sample size number of people you
find for for instance 90
of the gene at least one person
who carries a mutation a human lookout
and that was confirmed for instance
recently
when at the uk biobank they sequenced
hundred and twenty thousand examples
because now technology is there
you can sequence big time exams
and when they did hundred and twenty
thousand exams they essentially
confirmed what we had predicted and was
originally pointed
here by the guys in your study there are
human workouts they are rare
it's a matter of looking for them but
once you find them they are informative
and that is really the rational for the
circ program
which i have initiated here and for
which i have been hired at mcgill
so the research program
is funded by the federal government to
10 million mcgill 10 million in other
sources
5 million for 7 years it's here in
montreal
based and we wanted to make it
province-wide because
there is also a french canadian rare
disease heritage i hope this slide to
cloudberry who is in the audience here
she is my senior postdoc
and essentially she pointed out to me
that
rare diseases is a big issue in quebec
that people have been doing genetics for
200 years now in this
province that there is a whole series of
diseases which are known to be very
specific to this population but
surprisingly enough there is no
systematic analysis
of the architectural function encoding
variance that means the human knockouts
in particular
in this population and that's really the
gap that claude and realty
are wanting to fill
so the mission of the circle we have
received is
shown here is essentially to contribute
to the discovery and development of
innovative therapeutics using genomic
medicine
sounds very simple it's a bit
complicated
we our vision here is to build up
over the seven year period
a one-stop shop to support drug
discovery and development
we want to capitalize on functional
variants including these human knockouts
the
predicted loss of functions pilaf and we
want
to capitalize as well on the experiments
by nature
in the french canadian in cosmopolitan
cosmopolitan population of quebec
the french canadian heritage being
mostly due to the fact that
we now have a few million people which
are originally just derived from 8 000
people who colonized
these provinces back 300 years ago
so the strategy is shown here
that's the strategy we want to put in
place now for the next years
we want to build up first a large
reservoir
of patients that we can sequence the u
the
genome or the exon we call it the quebec
clinical mendelio
and it's really mcgill-affiliated
hospitals
cartagene which is a population-based
study of 40 000 people
in our quebec partner hospitals and our
plan
is to do whole exome sequencing like
i've been showing you or whole genome
sequencing
and identify these carriers of mutations
and then pro ask these individuals these
carriers to
go for back to the clinic or
if data is available through their
medical records and here ai
would be really so important to examine
these
people very carefully and potentially
like the starting story i mentioned to
you before
do pharmacological interventions on
genetically selected individuals
to that end we need a very strong
computational genomics group
and so claude is part of this group we
recently hired as well
a very talented individual from michigan
university daniel italian who is now
joining our team
and will be heading the computational
genomics group
i want to show you next in the in this
last
part of my presentation is three
enabling projects that we have initiated
since my arrival
here and the one project is to show
our capacity to generate a province-wide
effort
and actually kovit unfortunately gave us
this opportunity to demonstrate our
capacity to do so
is the quebec covid19 biobank which i
have presented before
claude in a group have generated
the first map of the coding values in
the french canadian
population which i will show you one
example of
and we are also developing at the genome
center
technology for sequencing a
large number of exams
at limited cost so i just want to go
quickly over these three programs the
first
is the covid19 biobank i've been
presenting that before this afternoon
it's a mandate which we received from
the founder
quebec the significant chief
of the province engineering quebec
daniel code
before the wave
we didn't have any patients in the
hospitals almost there
and they gave me the mandate do build a
bio bank
so that we can have the data in samples
from future
patients hospitalized in the province
we received the mandate in march two
days later we had a task force in place
ten days later we got approval from the
ethics committee
11 days later we started recruitment and
brent richards has been
extremely instrumental there at the
jewish general hospital
a couple of months later we had a
thousand patients recruited
and we got the public health agency of
canada to support further our projects
the first gus data so the genotyping
data was really
17th of july
we have recruited so far 1400 people at
the end of wave one we had 1200
participants already which makes it one
of the largest biobank in the world for
people
purposes and i'm just wanting to show
you here one piece of data again it's
from brent richards lab at the jewish
but what brent has been doing is used
genetics
to identify potential drug targets
for repositioning and
new indication into covid19 and
i don't have time to go into these
details but
just want to illustrate here the power
of genetics
to identify four different
molecules circulating in blood which are
associated
potentially causally with cov19 and as
such
represent potential drug for uh
repositioning for kobi
indications
the the second enabling project as you
remember
is analyze the genomic architecture of
coding variants
including these human knockout
variations in the french canadian
population
and that's with the work that claude has
been doing in collaboration with john
ryu
uh john being at the astitude cardiology
demo here
the data shown here refers to 2500
exons which have been sequenced by
the mit and
what claude has done is looked
at all the mutations in these 2500
exomes and she found 9 000 mutations
which are abolishing the function of the
protein so
human knockouts they are rare most of
them very vast majority are found only
once
in 2 000 people and then what she did
it she looked at the relative frequency
the frequency in the fresh canadian
population compared to
the frequency in a non-finnish
european population and so if these
violence had the same prevalence
in quebec and in the european population
we would have
essentially a distribution around one
but we have here a second peak
illustrating enrichment
these variants and look at the numbers
1400 for instance here 1200 these
variants
are more than tenfold more prevalent
here than they are
in europe and when you plot them
individually
each dot here representing one variant
and this is the line of identity europe
french canadians if we had the same
frequency
we would be around here but there are
lots of variants actually which
now are known to cause diseases in our
french canadian population
and so it's now the demonstration that
we have here
unique population to work with
because these population have variants
that are found almost
nowhere else and can be used to support
drug discovery and development
uniquely
the third thing is how we can detect
this rare coding variants
with new technologies we on we want to
spend less than 200 dollars to analyze
the entire
genome for our purposes and actually
we're making real progress
into these directions
so to conclude my presentation and open
up the discussions
i hope i have convinced you that the
large-scale genomics
represent a powerful new tool in the box
to support target identification target
validation and also
to open up next generation of proof of
concept trials
for investigation medicine very small
trials
very informative very decisive
we strongly believe that the environment
here in quebec
is unique to capture this opportunity
because of the founder population
and the enrichment i mentioned to you
because of the environment with
the academic industrial environment and
all the capabilities in genomics
and ar plus the clinic
the circ which i'm sharing uh
is now in place we have the foundations
in place we have enabling projects
demonstrating a capacity
to build up this program and so we're
moving towards a unique source of data
which will combine
clinical laboratory and genomic data for
ai
and other explorations just want to
finish up here my slide by
expressing my gratitude to these
people here including claude and the
people who made it possible to build up
to quebec biobank
and john ryu and his team as well for
sharing generously with us
is exam data so i'm done
and i thank you for your attention what
i
propose now is uh to leave two minutes
uh if you have questions and maybe you
can
ask your questions in the q a box
and i'll come back in two minutes to
read them okay i have the first question
here from muhammad
does cirque workflow involve any
transcriptomics data
at any of the step
the answer is yes we will be looking at
transcriptomic data
uh transcriptomic is not our focus
but transcriptomic data can be very
helpful because
they are allowed to identify as well
coding variants of course
that's the first thing the second thing
is in the quebec
biobank which i briefly described here
we are doing systematic transcriptomic
analysis and we are collecting
the pax gene tubes for doing
transcriptomics
on peripheral white blood cells isolated
from completely infected patients
so that will be an arm that we will be
exploring netanyahu
can i read your question nathaniel what
is the framework with which circ plans
to work with companies
during grafton sequencing efforts how
would data be shared
would local international companies be
of interest well that's an
important series of questions natalie
thanks for raising that
the first thing is
yes we are developing
this resource to promote the discovery
and development of new drugs
in quebec and in canada
that's the first thing the second thing
is
we want to work with the network of
companies
which are active here and for instance
our goal or in
three four years when we have put
everything in place is that companies
could come
to quebec to us and ask questions do we
have genetic data to support
our target or validate it to find
optimal indications or alternative
medications
do you have patients who carry mutations
within our target chains
and can we do trials on these
individuals so that's
the goal to make a one-stop shop for
companies
uh i have worked for in companies i've
spent 10 years
in pharma so i'm lucky enough to have
been behind the scene
and have sort of real hand
exposure into what it is to discover and
develop new drugs
i think that these
serb program builds a unique
spot which is very
difficult for farmer to access pharma
is so good at doing the ncros
are doing the phase one the volunteer
studies healthy volunteer studies they
are so good at
doing the large phase three trials but
these sweet spots here proof of concept
studies
are very difficult and we believe that
we can occupy
these this part
we believe that this spot is unique as
well
if we're thinking computational genomics
functional genomics
farmer can do that in-house they have
access to data
enormous amount of data you get biobank
data they don't have these
patients to do this type of studies in
this sweet spot
so that's where we want to to be that's
where we want to promote
also interactions with industry we want
to do that
in a very scientific manner of course
we are academic we want to stay academic
but also we are fully aware that
it's not the job of academia to develop
new drugs that new drugs are being
developed by industry
and we can partner with them in a very
healthy and
sustainable manner
does it answer your question nathaniel
if not please do drop me a note martin
you're asking me about any plans to
investigate
non-coding variants the answer
is absolutely yes we are interested in
non-coding variants but we will
initially focus on coding ones for
two reasons the first reason
is we may have some of them which are
uniquely present in our population the
second is
reason is that they are easy to
interpret now
we are interested in non-coding variants
for
a variety of reasons as well firstly
non-coding variants can be very helpful
for polygenic risk scores and we will
use project risk scores
to for instance enrich in carriers
of coding mutations second there are
some non-coding variants which are of
course
very active transcriptionally for
instance and so we want to keep this
capacity to identify
people who have same gain or loss of
expression of genes to that end
what we are doing now with claude and
the group is
to develop technology to do exome
at a very uh big depth
so making sure that we we identify this
coding balance
and the rest of the genome at the
shallow depth
to identify encoding variants we are
also developing with daniel italian
include
new tools for imputation of
coding and encoding violence including
as well insertion deletions
there are no other questions let me
thank you all
for attending this presentation
uh i'm certainly happy to answer
questions otherwise we have
a website called
searchgenomicmedicine.ca or
something equivalent and uh thank again
for the organizers to
giving me the chance to share with you
our plans
thank you bye-bye